pasamos a nuestras secciones de salud
aquí en directo América en esta mañana
con más Romero mar Buen día para usted
Buen día Ángela vamos a hablar hoy en
salud de los impactos de la pandemia en
la educación de niños y de jóvenes
cuéntenos Sí lo hacemos con motivo de un
nuevo estudio publicado en nature human
behavior que agrega datos de 15 países
para encontrar esas tendencias comunes
que hay y que afectaron a más de 1600
millones de estudiantes que quedaron
encerrados en sus casas Durante los
primeros meses de la pandemia de covid
19 para comentar estos resultados del
estudio estamos con Oscar Franco
director del departamento de salud
pública de la Universidad de utrek
doctor Muchas gracias por volvernos a
acompañar aquí en la salud de directo a
América cuéntenos Cuáles son las claves
principales del estudio
si durante la pandemia hemos visto una
explosión de estudios que se han
presentado en este tema y en otros temas
y en este estudio en particular lo que
se hace resumir la mejor evidencia que
existe a nivel mundial sobre el impacto
que ha tenido la pandemia en el déficit
de aprendizaje y lo hacen utilizando 42
estudios como decías de 15 países tres
de esos en Latinoamérica Brasil México y
Colombia y miran Cómo ese déficit se ha
mantenido o aumentado en los últimos dos
años y medio y lo que encuentran es que
el impacto de la pandemia
se puede traducir en que ha reducido el
déficit de aprendizaje más o menos en un
trimestre
las cosas que se pueden extraer
positivas Es que este déficit no se ha
aumentado en los últimos dos años y
medio el aspecto negativo es que a pesar
de todo lo que se ha hecho ese déficit
no se ha podido reducir Entonces se ha
mantenido a través de tiempo Buscar un
saludo para usted y Cómo influyeron las
desigualdades socioeconómicas en este
retraso del aprendizaje
si por ejemplo no solamente en este
estudio sino en otra evidencia que se ha
encontrado ese trimestre que hablábamos
de déficit de aprendizaje que se
encuentra en promedio en esos quince
países es mayor en países como Colombia
México o Brasil que puede llegar a cinco
meses quizás son semestre
lo que estamos viendo Es que cuando
enfrentamos los confinamientos y cuando
los cuando los escuelas y los colegios
fueron cerrados
se limitó a utilizar la digitalización
como una solución y la solución no era
simplemente darle tabletas o un
ordenador o un computador a los niños
sino tener en cuenta que también hay que
tener acceso a internet hay que tener el
espacio suficiente para poder aprender y
también el apoyo de los padres y en este
estudio se encontró que en las
poblaciones de bajo universo
socioeconómico y de países de bajo nivel
socioeconómico la evidencia es limitada
Pero se ve un impacto que es mucho mayor
doctor también queríamos preguntarle Más
allá de estos retrasos de aprendizajes y
también hemos visto que la pandemia Y
estos encierros tengan un impacto en el
desarrollo cognitivo de los jóvenes y de
los niños sobre todo en edades más
tempranas
sí una cosa para Resaltar desde este
estudio que me pareció muy interesante
es que el impacto en ese déficit de
aprendizaje fue mayor en el área de
matemáticas quienes de lectura y esto
tiene mucho que ver también con el apoyo
que puede ser de los padres para ayudar
con las tareas de leer o de aprender a
comprender la lectura y con mayor
complicación para las matemáticas Más
allá de esto lo que hemos visto Es que
la la pandemia el confinamiento ha
tenido un impacto en la Salud Mental ha
tenido un impacto en la capacidad de
interactuar con otros en la cohesión
social en la interacción y también en el
desarrollo motriz Entonces es importante
mirar Dentro de este punto de vista
todos los aspectos que pueden afectar a
los niños y enfocarnos en un desarrollo
completo holístico de los niños Bueno
entre tanto nos preguntamos Cuáles
pueden ser las consecuencias de una
generación perdida en aprendizaje a
largo plazo
no llamaría esto una generación perdida
pero si una generación afectada por la
pandemia Yo creo que es importante
entender que lo que se ha hecho hasta
ahora ha permitido que ese déficit no se
aumente pero no lo hemos podido evitar
que no lo hemos podido reducir y es
importante que podamos hacer algo lo
antes posible para evitar que ese
déficit permanezca si ese déficit
permanece puede tener impacto en la
capacidad de las personas para poder
ingresar en el mercado laboral en
términos de cohesión social Pero también
en desarrollo económico
Pues muy bien doctor le agradecemos
mucho Marc creo que tiene aún una
pregunta más Sí pero quería preguntarle
muy brevemente desde el punto de vista
epidemiológico si era Inevitable así en
sí no
yo creo que en el punto en el que
tomamos las decisiones en era Inevitable
no sabíamos el comportamiento del virus
y priorizamos la protección de los niños
y priorizamos esa protección creyendo
que cerrando los los centros académicos
podría ser la solución muy pronto
durante la pandemia vimos que esta no
era la solución y los colegios empezaron
a abrir yo creo que mirar hacia atrás es
importante hacerlo para poder aprender
lo que podemos hacer mejor hacia futuro
siempre es más fácil mirar hacia atrás
Gracias
por traernos este tema aquí directo
América y bueno continuamos con la
programación continuamos